sans rire c'est collector c'est une des
dernières d'une série limitée il y en a
plus c'était la star d'nrj12 en
l'occurrence c'était moi les dédicaces
et gmail à lui à faire conclut et
j'aimerais qu'on ait sur scène parce que
les chroniqueurs ont ramené des objets
alors vous c'est quoi donc un minitel
celui des premières générations minitel
un oui on est dans les années située à
bort l'art d'un expert écran pc
merci merci et ben voilà ils ont créé
sur mac lesggy oui le faire et en
1983-1984 183 première génération
minitel effectivement vous en attendez
entre 5000 et 10000 euros non sens je
pense non je pense alors que les faits
s'ils étaient chômeurs qu'on m'écoute je
pense que ça vaut plus de 100 euros
santoro fabrice fabrice est ce qu'il
fonctionne alors il fonctionne
parfaitement bien et fonctionnent prise
il ya même le président téléphone il est
la prise électrique très bien et il
fonctionne alors il sert à rien parce
que maintenant il ya plus de réseau oui
tout ça n'excuse l'actif c'est l'achat
ouais elle est professionnelle jusqu'au
bout des choses j'ai même gardé un be
bop
ça me plaît à aujourd'hui mais que c'est
assez exceptionnel combattu mais la
corde 2 euros 2 euros
combien julien c'est c'est super has
been quand même et c'est passé has been
pour voleurs de l'argent grâce à passer
comme nous 5e romanesque est ce qu est
ce que tu le costume miserait deux fils
et un bon tailleur on peut faire un truc
500 militaires tu parles 5 euros ou pas
tu gardes tu es comme celui de la prod
avec plaisir
[Rires]
non mais on va pas faire tout le monde
finalement c'est râpé alors au début
sophie je voulais vendre bien on
annoncera moi ça a c'est à toi c'est un
full méca aimé mais je ne le dois à moi
je ne vends pas je regarde comment ça va
faire une scène alors en revanche sans
rire c'est collector c'est une des
dernières d'une série limitée il y en a
plus c'était la star d'énergies douces
en l'occurrence c'était moi les
dédicaces et c'était juste après vous
pour la petite histoire j'avais tiré à
100 donc les pour les fans de lanmeur
dirais oui c'est la dernière et c'est
également la dernière avec cette couleur
que j'avais été me briand misandres et
que c'est plus au genre magnifique une
offre 10 euros pour tous ouais pour cet
égard des 100 ans du doré au qatar
d'énergie tous sont logés pas été ça
c'est toi je pense que julie argent tu
peut en offrir un peu plus surtout s'il
vient de livrer chez toi alors 20 euros
voleront 20 euros c'est pas mal mais
c'est pas au prix auquel je voulais le
vendre à ce que vous pourriez faire un
effort attendiez combien j'en attendais
100 euros peut-être mieux 100euros quoi
quoi t'as vu ce que j'ai fait j'ai fait
toute la chaîne on est monté à 2.8 des
délais
cinquante cinq au maximum est fait pour
ça mais pousse l'euro mais qu'est ce que
tu m'emmerdes 60 euros soixante années
qu'ils étaient prêts mais c'est quand
même toutes les données c'est c'est
l'animateur de ou 60 à 80 je cède je
prends ces bons 82 81 82 puis 14
euros/mwh à 81,2 mêler ma 14h les
médecins anglais à 80 dollars alésien
racing attendait à toni 82 euros pour la
fonte ou de delormeau oui mais non non
c'est pas la cgt cl je salue le soutien
et la photo mais ça vaut que dal
c'est la faute aux combats pour 82 chez
toi 0 a laissé la vie chère ont déconné
700 000 donne raison
c'est une petite statuette comment on
avait remarqué comme il sait que j'aime
bien le 19e siècle m'avait offert au
tout début de notre mariage ou qu'ils
avaient dû casser sa tirelire donc si ça
se trouve d'après vos têtes il s'est
fait avoir et donc ça serait presque un
nouvel avait payé savaria ce à plusieurs
centaines d'euros
c'est à dire plusieurs centaines communs
du genre de 700 nuit sa section grâce à
votre mari
[Rires]
non c'est un front là ouais à la
sesterce il a payé ses dettes ou peu
après il nous dit poussé ben ali à
ploemel qu'ils s'adoraient quoi maximum
entre 60 et 80 euros au maximum
maxime avait bien commencé entrés
légalement leurs actifs d'accord ouais
vous le vendez à 80 noms qu'ils aillent
se faire voir
comme la poudre heureusement qu'on a des
vendeurs puis sympathie va pas à ne veut
pas jouer mais merci merci d'avoir été
avec nous
[Musique]